It is the good news story that the Japanese people have been craving.
An 80 - year - old woman and her 16 - year - old grandson...
...found alive in the wreckage of their house in Ishinomaki, Miyagi prefecture.
Local media reports they survived by eating yoghurt from the fridge.
Eventually, the boy managed to break through to the roof.
Rescue workers spotted him waving for help.
They have survived nine nights of freezing temperatures and heavy snow.
The boy is reported to have a low temperature but is conscious.
It will reinvigorate the rescue effort here.
For days, Japanese and international teams have searched up and down this wrecked coastline in vain.
But for most families, the desperate search for loved ones goes on or ends in tragedy.
Miyagi police say 15,000 people probably died in their prefecture alone.
Here in Natori, close to Sendai city,...
...the body of a teenage boy is left on the side of the embankment.
A nameless corpse yet to be collected and taken to the overwhelmed morgue.
Rescuers say there are many more bodies among the wreckage of this town.
The rest of the missing, they say, were probably washed out to sea.
Natori was on the front line when the tsunami smashed into the shoreline.
Anyone who had not escaped this flat coastal plain had little chance.
Henry Ritchwell for VOA News, Natori, Japan.